okay so
we're going to start static and i'm
going to use my two tools
which is an arm drag and a knee pull
and i'm going to do the front inward
kazushi but i'm actually on the outside
of it this time
okay so i have my technique my knees go
and i have to move to the outside of it
but this is his balance
okay so right here he's leaning on me
this is not good enough
okay i have to get this to go over here
where he's actually falling into the
hole okay
and now i'm gonna find i'm gonna get off
my back in this side circle guard
all right now i have a couple ways of
doing this
if i throw him all the way it's just a
minor adjustment
and i can just do it by using my legs on
him
we'll start with the easiest one okay
but it's not the best one
so i'm doing everything the same i'm
going to take my foot often
off his back post it near
his foot i don't want to have it way out
here because he'll step over
into a mouth or a half guard go back
so when i take it off his back i'm aware
of where his foot is
try it again he'll find that much he's
much harder to step
over and i have to be fast so
over shrimp and then
re-close second option
i'm over here he goes a little i'm gonna
put my foot
on his on his hip and he'll find that
even harder to step
over but i can shrink on using that
holding the lat
next option is to i will uncross
my legs but i'll use his body
to shrimp on and go and then the best
option
is to just use the zushi and he's in
that position and i stay
uh center to center on him and i'm here
if he goes to punch boom i pass the
punch over
and take him into that kazushi and find
this side guard again and i'm not on my
back
and i'm trying to pin this shoulder very
much like an arm triangle i don't want
that arm to come free again
so we'll do it from two ways with the
arm drag
if you don't feel you're enough over
pick one of those three
to get in position close off the
shoulder
and then one from the punch go ahead
dude
throw them over and move into the same
position
okay
again we're gonna just stick with
the kazushi identification okay
so uh he throws his punch and i use
it taking it to this side okay
he wants to square me back up and lay me
back down
can you do it there that's what he wants
to do okay
so when i go here i immediately
come up and on this leg over here
underneath i have the front inward
kazushi
hip at that hook okay
this has the lap he goes to push
and i just take it the other way
so let me again identify the markers for
you we'll just do it off the off the arm
drag here
i'm here like this he's trying to push
me back
up this right here this right here
is the controlling the hip this is
controlling the head
so he goes to push and i just hook
over and you have the front inverse his
ushi
again but this time i'm i'm on the
inside again
not on the outside okay all right so
i i'm not gonna contest it i get over
here
i get here i move my arm out so bring
your elbow to
shoulder shoulder head height or above
that
and i go pull my elbow in i go
up okay now when he goes to
push i lower it
to do the kazushi
boom here he's trying to center me i
bring up my weights on him now
as he push keeps going i don't keep
going like this
his first push that he does after that i
healed
and you're in the front inward position
so everything is static for training
purposes
but the fight is gonna move so
things you can do static you won't be
able to do when the fight is moving okay
so i have uh two micro drills here
the first one is i just have the arm
drag
and the knee pull and then i have
this side guard here and i'm in okay
and the first two micro drills third
micro drill
is just how do i put weight on him and
we're doing it
inside taking us back okay so i'm gonna
create space bring my elbow in a
mechanically
sound place and then put it underneath
my shoulder very much
like a turkish get up this whole thing's
like a turkish get up
the second thing i'm paying attention to
is that my
head stays above his head anytime my
head is below his head he
will have a easy time putting me back
flat
on the mat okay so i've always cognized
it
that my head needs to be above his head
because then very much like kotakesh i
am on the outside
of that front inwards kazushi pattern so
when i come up
and i do my move here i don't want to
drop my head back down
because again though he's just gonna
roll me over
so i'm cognizant that my head stays
above his head
when i go to lift my hip up i don't let
my head drop
do you see i keep it up and then i get
even higher
now the bottom leg is free to move it's
all very easy
okay let's take so i'm
not working with the kozushi again i
still have this micro drill with the
knee pull
and the on the arm drag and then i still
have this micro drill
with seeking this car then we're gonna
keep working
on this thing of putting weight on him
so elbow under hit under me
then weight goes up i pay attention to
his head
up and i'm going to start climbing over
his body
and we're going to do the front kazushi
on his left side this time we've been
doing it on his right side
but i'm going to climb over i'm going to
keep this arm so he can't post it
so his arm's there i just keep it there
and then i'm going to attack this
shoulder with this leg
this hook is still doing his hip body
and we roll over
so two micro drills knee pull an arm
threat
side circle guard climbing drill
pay attention to his head weight goes on
him
boom i'm around him step up
to put weight on his shoulder over we go
so
hey